you know what I spent my time wondering
what what Ronnie and his therapist talk
oh I am obsessed with it sometimes I sit
in the car and he'll tell me a little
bit of the dialogue really tell Robin
why you was how to switch psychiatrist
cuz I was like pouring my heart out to
this guy one day yeah and I look up and
he's [ __ ] sleeping how did you sleep
I would have been Ronnie totally busted
him - like Ronnie was oh yeah
how did you wake him up I guess I said
am i boring you now what do you say he
probably didn't even understand he just
like jumped up you know like half asleep
and he said no I was just resting my
eyes
yeah [ __ ] he was out right dick ass
you knew as I saw at first I saw him
like dozing oh you saw him trying to
stay awake and you don't and I would
think being Ronnie's therapist [ __ ]
on me like when I busted him about it
didn't I tell you he ate a big meal or
something yeah well my point was like
right after he had lunch and I guess he
was like in the food coma every time he
must have some big lunch you know it
full of cards and I called his assistant
and I go I'm not really happy about this
I think I'm gonna split down on this guy
and she goes well maybe we can make
schedule your appointment before lunch
they must have complained but you come a
Giunta Ryan he's pretty interesting like
hey so I jerked off to my parents and
this guy they call and I'm like when I
was four I fingered my babysitter
tearing a wagon train on Television
Awards you sir and then and then i got a
gum job from an old massage therapist oh
yeah and my babysitter stuck a Lincoln
Log in my ears hey wake up you [ __ ] well
III thought about it afterwards I should
have just like snuck out any office yeah
II woke up I said to Ronnie you can't go
back here he's like I know I'm not going
I was I was totally done yeah I don't
even remember oh you could imagine why
don't work then this guy I know took a
[ __ ] in a box and throw it out the
window and [ __ ] box Ronnie came over
then was this chick how could you fall
asleep during Ronnie second well my
first my first session with the new guy
was you know telling him about what
happened what do you say laughing
laughing about that's a tie you
shouldn't laugh again inappropriate
behavior that's Ronnie gonna get cured
we couldn't Ronnie hasn't I didn't
you're sleeping I was pissed
I left what do you talk about what do
you mean I don't know what are you
talking about it a lot of things does he
know you wash your ass in the sink but
you're in there talking about me know
I've talked about you of course here
I've talked about you window tell me I
want to tape that session when you're
talking about me I've talked about you
yeah let me tell you something I'm a
damn good guy that's what you should
tell me tell you man we were loyal to
each other I know I'll be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] don't get all worked up and
don't let this guy [ __ ] lead you down
the road where I'm some kind of dick I'm
not gonna mention any names but this
prick got really angry at me for going
to Mexico recently powered Ernie you got
some [ __ ] nerve what you said why are
you bad-mouthing me for I [ __ ] did I
could see it on you you liar
yeah real pain this one [ __ ]
yelled at me for getting the wrong SUV
limousine yeah put the door on right
name a name right
stir it up